e
uh yes so amendments are about to
um open up the exact
session uh just uh quick announcement um
I I uh
I'm one of my tasks is I Am The Treasure
of uh my libraries trust fund and
they're having a meeting at one o'clock
so I really want to be out of here by
noon okay just go along with us we'll
all go along with everything we've done
here except if
the new women empowerment Bill okay well
that's what it is no okay well is true
that it turns out the vasectomies are
also a mandated so so that's a male
empowerment that's a male empowerment
okay all
right okay first one up is uh Senate
Bill
332 um I guess I'm making the motion of
uh interim study representative bro
I'll second
it any discussion on T Bill
332 seeing none the clerk will call the
role representative Amon
yes pusk yes post yes Cole yes muu
yes Chelly yes nexton yes Walsh yes
burrow yes Herbert yes clerk yes mclair
yes M Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan yes
grassy yes raor yes all right 18 and
Hunt I'm
sorry
yes okay the motion is is 18 to zip of
all those in favor of placing on the
consent Calendar please say I
so moved uh next up uh Senate Bill
333 uh representative burough second by
pass any discussion on the
motion seeing none the clerk will call
the role when she's ready to pass on 333
representative Ammon yes pusk
yes post yes Cole yes M
yes pelli
yes
yes yes okay motion carries excuse me
Jane could you turn on the microphone so
so that I can hear your uh I can hear my
name oh good
you all right uh uh motion to uh put it
on on the consent calendar uh all those
in favor please say I I those opposed so
moved
unanimously okay Senate Bill
334 uh representative hunt second Leed
by representative burough moves uh to
motion seeing none the clerk will call
the role right ought to pass
pusk yes post yes Cole yes M yes
pelli yes taxton yes Walsh yes Burrows
yes Herbert yes clerk yes M yes Gibbs
yes spear yes Sullivan
okay all those in favor of placing on
the consent Calendar please say I I
those opposed so move
inter I'm not gonna I didn't get in
touch
with Mar so recommendation we had we had
a to pass if I could find three reps oh
three reps but we're just gonna enter
stud we did found a three reps okay
uh well I didn't have any communication
with the uh we have one did one yeah
well he he wanted to I think you were
the only one no I was going to no no you
know I Mr Mr chairman I look at this
bill as as being something it's a
feel-good bill if we do it that's good
and it may help if we don't do it I
think you know I don't think there's
anything lost um I I think it would be a
good thing to do it doesn't cost any
money and if we can find three people
that are willing to participate do it
all right so we got in versus doing an
interim study which would we'd keep it
in the committee and do the study yeah
yeah how either one is
fine either one is fine okay did then
finding no Well Carrie said she would do
it and I will do it as well but I didn't
I didn't talk to any any Republicans 477
oh you didn't have any Republicans I
didn't you didn't have any Republicans
that's the problem I was wait I was
waiting to speak and if you don't have
any then let's put interim study at
least we can look at the
issue all right interim study
yeah
yeah so okay representative bullo second
in by representative uh Ammon Mo's
interim
study any discussion on the
role representative Ammon yes
pusk yes post yes Cole yep M yes pelli
yes Daxton yes Walsh yes burrow yes
Herbert yes Clark yes M yes Gibbs yes
spear yes
Sullivan grassy yes rafter yes chairman
hunt yes and all those in favor placeing
on the consent Calendar please say I I
those opposed so moved unanimously
okay next one Senate Bill
97 representative Cole seconded by
representative Ammon uh moves uh interim
motion seeing none the clerk will call
the
role representative Ammon
yes pusk yes
yes Cole yes
B yes belli yes Maxon Walsh yes Burrows
yes Herbert yes clerk yes mclair
no Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan yes grassie yes
rafter yes chairman hunt yes
represent M you have any problems
putting on the consent
calendar okay all those in favor of
consent please say I I those opposed so
moved
okay representative Ammon seconded by uh
representative pusk moves uh interim
study is there any discussion on the
motion
you want I thought that we had I thought
that we were going OTP on
this the no the lithium battery was no
we were we need to make sure everybody
everything's covered on it okay okay if
that's the case we were we were we
needed to get the right standards get
all the right stand compl we need and
you certainly need the iso standard
exactly
yeah okay inm study all right any
discussion on the motion seeing none the
representative Ammon yes pusk yes post
yes Cole yes M yes melli yes Daxton yes
Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yeah clerk
yes mle yes Gibbs yes Speer yes
Sullivan grassy yes Raptor yes and
chairman hun
yes 18 to
zero okay all those in favor of placing
on the consent Calendar please say I
those
opposed was that 17 to zip and 18 18 oh
it's all 18
was okay next up is uh five
515 okay
uh representative uh what we got what5
Cole second by representative buros
moves um on to
pass all those in
favor clerk will call the rooll sorry
fast all right representative Ammon yes
pusk yes post yes Cole yes yes belli yes
Axton yes Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert
yes clerk yes
M
yes Gibbs yes beer yes Sullivan grassy
yes rafter yes chairman Hut yes 18 to
zero 18 zip all those in favor of
placing on the consent Calendar please
okay
366 representative spear second by
represent Ammon moves inexpedient to
legislate is there any discussion on the
motion do you want one
noar Spear and
amm I got to get out of here
on okay all right any discussion on the
motion seeing none the clerk will call
legislate representative Ammon yes pusk
yes post yes Cole yes M yes pelli yes
taxton Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert
no Clark yes maer yes Gibbs yes spear
I'm sorry
yes Sullivan yes grassy yes Raptor yes
chairman hunt yes
171 okay the vote is 17 to1 all those in
favor of the consent Calendar please say
I I those opposed so mov
damous all right uh First Amendment
502 so representative hunt second by
representative buroughs moves the
1896 uh I'll briefly speak to this
amendment does everybody have the
amendment this is uh in my 38 years this
has never happened
before so I can always say that you some
first time for everything so we had to
change the title because it said non-
driver's license that was not the
issue any other discussion on the
Amendment good okay all right so the
motion right now is out to pass on the
amendment number 1896 the clerk will
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes yes pelli yes baxton
yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
Clark yes M yes g g
yes spear sorry
yes
pivan grassy yes rafter yes chairman
hunt yes 18 to zero okay uh now the
motion is ought to pass as amended any
discussion on the motion seeing none the
clerk will call the rule in a minute in
ready to pass is
yes representative Ammon
yes pusk yes poost yes po yes the yes
belli yes taxton Walsh yes burrow yes
Herbert yes clerk yes M yes Gibs yes
spear yes Sullivan yes grassy yes rafter
yes chairman hun yes and this was
otpa right okay all those in favor
placing on the consent Calendar please
say I I those opposed so moved
unanimously okay next up
173 representative Spears second ined by
representative
moves ought to pass is there any
discussion on the
none all right the clerk will call the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes M yes belli yes daxon
Walsh yes Barrow yes Herbert yes Clark
yes M yes Gibbs yes spear yes
salivan grassie yes rafter yes hunt yes
chairman hunt 18 to zero motion carries
to vote 18 to zip all those in favor
placing on the consent Calendar please
unanimously okay next up uh Senate Bill
176 representative hunt seconded by
representative Bros moves in expedient
to
legislate is there any discussion on the
motion see none the clerk will call the
role did we have a find out just a
comment yeah this was all so the study's
been done already the department already
did the study all right I just never
heard of a the definition of public but
I'll get that later you want to
know I can I can I can research
it you weren't here for the hearing no I
don't think I no I because I wasn't
either so okay so the motion is
inexpedient to legislate the clerk will
role representative Ammon yes post
jaxton okay Walsh yes Burrows yes
Herbert yes clerk yes M yes Gibbs yes
spear
yes
pivan grassy yes rafter yes
chairman hunt yes 18 to zero okay the
motion carries all those in favor of
placing uh 176 on the consent Calendar
please say I I those opposed so move
damous okay next up Senate Bill
177 uh hang
one you don't have a sheet you're
missing a sheet
take the
it yeah well we'll just move
yeah holy
moly this is about as clear as chocolate
milk
CH no let's just keep moving until we
get you need a restroom break no she
wants to talk about oh okay we'll get
other we're going to do 177 uh in a
couple minutes okay krie needs to give
me sheet all right so moving on to the
3122 represent M second by
represent not we're excuse me after
we're gonna hold off on 177 because we
don't we all said you have a voting
sheet you have a voting I know but the
actual oh yeah you had that I fill that
out okay that was okay all right sorry
we'll go back to
177 all right so representative
by
okay 177 who said they want to
OTP okay any discussion on the motion to
177 all right seeing none the clerk will
right representative Ammon yes kusk yes
poost yes po yes M yes belli yes taxton
yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
clerk yes M yes Gibbs
yes spear yes
civan grassy yes rafter yes chairman
um all those in favor of placing on the
consent Calendar please say I I those
opposed so moved unanimously all right
312 all right representative
MCU second by representative Burrows
moves uh uh to pass is there any
okay the motion is ought to pass on 312
it's motion clear the clerk will call
the
role representative Ammon
yes pusk yes poost yes Cole yes M yes
belli yes daon yes Walsh yes Burrows yes
Herbert yes clerk yes M yes Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan yes grassy yes Raptor
yes tamon hunt yes 18 to
zero okay uh all those in favor placing
three12 on the consent Calendar please
say I I those opposed so moved
unanimously
353 uh I guess it's me uh repres second
represent Burrow's uh moves uh is this
oh this is this the bill we're
doing no this is 353 okay um the the
Down Syndrome yeah yeah can I say can I
say something y yes yeah just to clarify
why we're doing this um we got uh
interpretation of the bill that um
basically it the bill doesn't change
anything in terms of insurance coverage
for autism or down syndrome it basically
um updates the um disorder names of of
of um autism and down syndrome so it's
it's really not going to be harmful um
to interim study
it right and it would be good to clarify
these definitions to make sure they're
in the right place in the statute okay
is this was this hunt and Burrows or
Burrows and hunt
yeah all right is the question inter
room study is the question clear the
clerk will call the role representative
Ammon yes pusk yes H yes Cole yes M yes
belli yes Faxton yes Walsh yes Burrows
yes Herbert yes Clerk yes Mair yes Gibbs
spear yes grassie yes
Sullivan rafter yes chairman hunt yes 18
to zero okay vote it's 18 to zip all
those in favor placing on the consent
Calendar please say I I those opposed so
moved
unanimously okay next up uh Senate Bill
okay representative buroughs seconded by
representative hunt moves to
pass any discussion on the
motion seeing
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes M yes pelli yes taxton
yes Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes
Clark yes Mair yes Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan grassy yes rafter yes chairman
hunt yes 18 to
zero okay all those in favor of placing
in the consent Calendar please say
I those was
opposed so moved damle okay
all right so now we're down to okay
we're now we're at
56 407 was already
done okay
556 uh represent we have an amendment
okay so representative spear second by
representative hunt moves out to pass on
1785 and representative spear do you
want to speak to your motion or I can do
you the essentially the uh forget about
looking it up essentially the amendment
changed uh provider to APRN uh advanced
practice uh AP registered nurse and
that's essentially what the amendment
what it does not essentially that is it
is what it
does okay all right is there any
discussion on the motion uh V to pass on
the amendment seeing none the clerk will
representative Ammon yes austic yes post
yes Cole yes the yes pelli yes zon yes
Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes clerk
yes mclair yes Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan yes grassy yes rapor
yes chairman hunt yes 18 to zero on the
Amendments okay now the motion is uh
ought to pass as
second okay any discussion on the motion
of about to pass as
amended seeing none the clerk will call
representative Ammon yes
pusk poost yes Cole yes M yes pachelli
yes baxton yes Walsh yes Burrows yes
Herbert yes clerk yes mclair yes Gibbs
yes spear yes Sullivan yes grassy yes
rafter yes chairman hunt yes 18 to zero
okay all those in favor of uh placing it
on the consent Calendar please say oh
was it did I do yeah that was yeah
placeing on the consent Calendar please
say I those opposed so move
damous and we are in
recess
okay is insurance department you guys
have you guys chance to read this
amendment
are you okay are you guys do you
understand what it says because it it's
I've never seen more gobbly G in a in an
amendment
yeah
ah yeah the it's the RSA that was the
other problem with this bill was the RSA
354 the first bunch of lines all the way
until you get to 12 stay exactly as they
were what this is saying is that b is
taking out it's just changing section
um well this is not exactly what you had
described to me it's what I was trying
to get to I hear you and and now you see
in live in In Living Color why we we do
Amendment so here's we can do a floor
Amendment we can do a Flor am so uh
let's do the inter room study motion now
well we're not going to do an not to
pass motion so I'm just I'm saying right
now we were we were talking about itl so
I'm just suggesting that we do an
interim study motion and you and I can
work and then we can see if we can find
something that that we can El that gets
to what you're trying to
do okay and what you are trying to do is
you want to make it just like the
vasectomy are you saying that it's not
possible to do that today at this moment
no I mean to ask this wait no I I don't
want to stick I don't want to stick I
mean I I not withstanding I will
disappoint all those board members in my
library that I don't show up but that
for us to then get this amendment you
this this is the pro why we have
subcommittee we go to subcommittees we
work these things out we get these
things structured right and then we
bring then once we know we've got it
right I understand all that so all I'm
just saying is I am certainly willing to
help you to see if we can do something
differently and it conceivably it could
end up being a floor Amendment and it
absolutely could be a floor Amendment if
we can find something we can agree on
all right all right we have that
recorded it's on
YouTube there
forever okay could could representative
spear tell us exactly what you're trying
to do I I'm a little bit
confused what I want the way I want this
to end up or the way I'm hoping it ends
up is that whether the uh any person any
person with a
uterus whether they are
heterosexual bisexual whatever they are
whatever they are they are entitled to
six rounds per year of
IUI and it's not considered infertility
I read through the laws on infertility
and they have a very fuzzy outline and
this fits right above that is the 417 G1
is that the treatment the IV what is it
IUI IU you want IUI can it be ivi Oh you
mean IV over there
IVF which one are you talking about what
what is the actual treatment IUI I'm
looking now at the department what is
I I believe the bill that in its current
form without an amendment is relating to
IUI right which is one very specific
treatment and it's allowing up to six
rounds of IUI per plan year right
that's what we want but then there's all
this other stuff in in the down well
because the chapter relates to
infertility this mandate to require
coverage for IUI is absent a diagnosis
of infertility so you can get these six
rounds of IUI whether you've been
diagnosed with any woman regardless of
their status yes without a diagnosis of
INF without a diagnosis of infertility
that's that's section one of the bill
that's the chapter that exists what the
bill would change is putting in this IUI
and that is absent a finding of
infertility everyone has access to that
if you have a finding of but wasn't
there another section in that bill that
had all these labor stuff on it yes
that's what the amendment is ADD so if
bill well yeah one and
two one and two is the short title and
what it changed
section I believe that you're that's
what I'm looking for so two sections one
and two so two just simply says that any
it but it does have that infertility
statement in regardless of infertility
it says in there right yes so you don't
have to have a diagnosis of infertility
to be able to access this specific
treatment right everything else in the
chapter you have to have a diagnosis of
infertility that sounds good and so if
we just pass one and two and then I
guess we uh delete that but we still
need the effect date of January 1
yes okay well it could be 60 days
because this is for a large group right
section oh yeah that's got to be January
1 January 1 would be better yeah section
one
is monitoring economy act where did the
hell that come from January 1st no
modern economy act I don't know where
that came from I thought that meant
something to you like like solely was
that what this bill originally was and
then they gutted it and put something
else in it sorry what was section one of
the B oh it had to do with the other
stuff it just it'll get it'll get
theoretical get retitled I guess yeah
this bill originally started as
something much more ambitious and this
is what has been whittel down to so
initially included stuff like IVF that's
why it's up in the the higher title the
ACT um but that has gone through many
revisions with the stakeholders there
still way we could do it today I I no
because it's it it's let's we'll do a
floor Amendment okay we'll do a floor
then let's not vote on it right now no
no we have to vote we have to do it m Mr
chairman yes if we took a vote to OTP
and I know there are a number of flaws
in here knowing that a floor Amendment
will be coming up and if your side
decides to vote against it and our side
decides to go for it it's going to come
up with no recommendation and then it
can go to the floor and we can do
whatever we want to do no we don't want
to do that we don't we're gonna have an
amendment we're gonna have a debate
anyway well I no not necessarily
not necessarily because if we if we have
an understanding what we're what she
wants to get at which was the the
original t not the original the one
paragraph here and uh and we and
obviously we need to change the title
and we need to change the effective date
uh we there's some things that need to
be changed well the effective date has
changed all right because the amendment
has that okay I'm just saying is we want
to clean up but in interim study means
that the bill will always if if if
something bad were to happen on the
floor when we try to do something at at
least that the pending motion from this
committee is interim study we can work
on and get it done right but I was just
saying is for that if we just do that
and yes I am certainly committed to
working to try to get you an amendment
that that I could live with and I can't
speak for all the Republicans in the
committee but I'm I'm pretty sure well I
know I don't have some votes but I'm I'm
just concerned this bill taking another
year to get passed that's the thing and
I think this is important enough that we
need to get it passed now and I fear if
you put an inm study motion on the floor
regardless if we we have Amendment or
not there's a chance it could get passed
which delays this bill for another year
and it's just the same thing as it
telling it so that's why I would rather
see an OTP go to the floor than an I
don't see the UR I don't see the urgency
of this bill look why don't we ask
Kristen how long would it take her to
just add to take out one more paragraph
Just you we're no can't have it done by
noon why not I don't understand to have
this amendment done by noon I had it
done in an hour to begin with that's how
I came in this morning early and they
depend on whether you have a library
meaning I'm
sorry okay yes represent Ammon I I just
representative spear could you explain
can you speak a little louder I'm having
a lot of trouble representative could
you could you explain the amendment
because what I read here it's unlawful
discrimination fertility treatment but
then it it and then it exempts fertility
from the amendment that's the way it
me yeah what we just discussed was to
take out section three add that to the
part that was taken out so that all that
would be left would be one and
two don't do this amend I'm sorry no the
amendment isn't going to work because we
need to take out more than what was in
there and the part that you're talking
about needs to come out why don't we
just take a vote and then we'll vote on
what what are we voting on oh because we
can't we're voting on letting people
have right no but but we probably in all
in all due respect
repres my honor here my word here is
that I absolutely worked I've already I
I I agreed intent on what was proposed
all right so and then all I'm asking is
just do the interation now I will be the
one who gets up there and tell everybody
to vote
no on the inter room study and then I
introduce the new Amendment okay okay
all right that's the deal I think that's
fair you I I think John's not a bad
actor he's not a bad faith actor when it
comes so what we're aiming for is a
floor Amendment and you're going to help
me write it just can I just say
something can you please include the
ranking members when you put this
together that's all absolutely it would
not be just her okay of course not of
course not I think that's a good move
for the record if we were to get in any
committee conferences or any of these
discussions and we do have two um uh
concurrences right now I will always
include
you representative bars always okay is
tonight okay all right excuse me
no all yeah just before you do anything
else think you need to take us out of
recess I know I know do but I just want
to make clear what we're going to where
we are could you just summarize what
we're doing
exactly okay so the expectation is that
we will uh pass the inter room study
motion uh and then we will work on
trying to create an amendment that will
absolutely be distributed to all the
members of the committee so that you can
explain to your
seatmates how this committee that never
had a bill on the regular calendar is
now suddenly going to have one uh
because we knew that this floor
amendment was coming and that uh this
that that you know they certainly are
free to vote whatever they want to fruit
but that the committee um is committed
to at least bringing forward this other
Amendment and and and and you're going
to speak to it and say how wonderful it
is speak and I'm going to say that it is
a perfect Amendment for women
empowerment I heard you say it that word
please do
I got to say something else okay yes
okay I just need to say this because you
talked about women empowerment and I
this is not an attack on you
because don't wor no no it isn't it
isn't John it isn't Mr chair but I guess
one of the things that has my hackles up
is that and one of the reason this bill
is so important to many people in this
committee is that the speaker of the
house uh it was supposed to be a nice
Mother's Day uh declaration came out
with a declaration saying that it's um
national natural family month and if you
go on to look at the wording behind the
foundation that put it out it said that
there has to be a male male head of the
household so that's one reason some of
us have our hackles up right now about a
bill that involves uh same seex
couples but not justes same this this
bill it says but it will help get
pregnant it help samex couples it's but
it's not just same seex couples come on
it's it's I've been the head of my
household forever my husband wouldn't
word all right it represented
faction
[Laughter]
so my as someone who's been on the spent
40 years on the receiving end of
legislation that was cobbled together
without
fully working it out I appreciate the
effort of this committee and this this
bill basically in no way involves me
personally but uh good to know um you
know I and I get that this is really
wicked important to some people and
maybe not important to other people but
to those people who it's important to
it's really
important everybody's better off if we
take a deep breath and go down this road
of let's put together the amendment
that's really right right because when
you get we saw earlier today you know
non- drivers licenses what what is that
you know so it's not what we want
organizationally we'd like to have it
all done and be out of here but take the
deep breath accept the reality that we
need to do what we're doing and then
hopefully you guys can get together an
amendment that everybody agrees on I
agree I agree and but I do also
appreciate your willingness to work on
this with me and that we can get it out
to the floor I think that's very
important I absolutely this is why
that's why I keep running me and and yes
I will be running for another ter just
to
official okay I'm going for the the big
40 okay any other discussion on uh on
the motion of interim study no excuse me
we now I will now take us out of recess
we're now back into our executive
session so the pending motion I will
create I guess I haven't got a pending
motion right so we're doing
558 so representative hunt seconded by
study any discussion on the
motion seeing none the clerk will call
representative Ammon yes pusk yes post
yes Cole yes M yes belli yes baxton yes
Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes clerk
yes mclair yes Gibs yes spear yes
Sullivan yes grassy yes rafter yes
hunt hunt 18 to zero
okay the vote is uh 18 to zip all those
in favor of leaving this on the regular
Calendar please say
yes well yes oh it has to be consent
calendar no no no to where I normally
you don't have to do this but I want an
affirmative vote because someone might
come in and say why did you guys vote 18
to zip and then put it on the regular
calendar I want that that yes we we are
I want an affirmative vote that we put
it we voted to put keep this on the
regular calendar so all those in favor
of keeping this on the regular Calendar
please say yes yes those are opposed so
moved unanimously okay we're on to the
next
one all
right yeah you don't you don't have to
worry about yeah just leave regular
calendar yeah you just leave alone yeah
okay okay uh next up five
61 representative
MCU second by representative burough
moves out to pass is there any
motion seeing none the clerk will call
the
representative Ammon yes pusk yes poost
yes Cole yes M yes belli yes Daxton yes
Walsh yes Barrow yes Herbert yes clerk
yes mclair yes Gibbs yes spear yes tvan
grassy yes rafter yes chairman hunt yes
18 to zer
okay vote is 18 to zip all those in
favor placing on the consent Calendar
please say I I okay those opposed so
moving
namly all right next up uh Senate Bill
amendment
okay on
this is the whole
thing okay so this is a re rewrite of
whole right
right
okay um so I know that there was some
concern about um
what section was it relly that you
worried about
numeral line
three okay independent charity patient
assistance program means okay so um my
understanding is this is actually
current statute and uh and so there and
the insurance department has assured me
that this is
okay okay all right so I will move ought
Burrows yeah
yeah okay any discussion on the
amendment
all right seeing none the clerk will
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes M yes belli yes Faxton
yes Walsh yes Barrow yes Herbert yes
clerk yes mcir yes IBS yes
spear
yes Sullivan grassie yes Raptor yes
chairman hunt
yes chairman hunt it chairman hunt I got
a question for you on this amendment on
line six you got 415 semicolon 18 FF and
the original amendment was 415 semicolon
28 is that a
typo uh no because I can see it's right
after 18
e okay so after e would be FF just mean
shows you how far down they are in the
the numeric system Al
numeric okay any all right so the motion
now is from representative hunt second
by representative buroughs moves ought
to pass as amended any discussion on the
motion seeing none the clerk will call
representative Ammon yes pusk yes post
yes Cole yes M yes melli yes jaxton yes
Walsh yes Barrow yes Herbert yes Clark
yes M yes Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan
yes grassie yes RoR yes
chairman hun yes 18 to zero okay a
motion to pass as amended as amended
okay all those in favor of placing it on
the consent Calendar please say I I
unanimously okay next up is Senate Bill
555 that's right representative MC did
you want to do some of these is that did
I I okay okay sorry well I'm sorry but I
I didn't update my spreadsheet okay so
let represent
M
uh
and well let's leave 354 with me because
I we already did it okay but you will do
355 okay all right so
uh represent second by representative
buroughs moves ought to pass on the
amendment to
by
great so basically the original bill um
did have a uh repeal of the current
statute and
uh which will then but the the repeal
was going to be as of as of I think July
1st so uh it's going to repal the
repeal and which is section one of this
amendment and then section two is that
the new the new law will take in
effect on the date of the original
repeal so basically the current law will
stay as
is any other any discussion on the
motion of to pass on the
amendment on the amendment on the
amendment
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Co yes M yes belli yes Daxton
yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
clerk yes
yes Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan grassie yes raor yes chairman
hunt yes 18 to zero on the amendment
okay motion now is ought to pass as
amended representative MCU second by
representative
Burrows any discussion on the motion it
ought to pass as amended see none the
representative Ammon yes pusk yes post
yes Co yes M yes pachelli yes daxon yes
Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes Clark
yes Mair
yes Gibbs yes Pier yes Sullivan yes
rassi yes Raptor yes Jim hunt yes 18 to
zero okay all all those in favor play on
calendar all those in favor play on the
consent Calendar please say I I those
[Music]
was different
order um okay uh representative MCU
second by representative burough Mo
motion seeing
none the clerk will call the rooll for a
okay all
right representative Ammon yes pusk yes
poost yes Cole yes M yes belli yes
baxton Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes
clerk yes
mclair yes Gibbs yes beer yes Sullivan
yes grassy yes rafter yes chairman hunt
yes 18 to zero all those in favor of
placing 557 557 on the consent Calendar
please say I I I opposed so moved
unanimously Senate Bill 196
representative Peli seconded by
representative
rafter moves
itl representative pcel do we like to
speak to your
motion yes uh the sponsor withdrew the
bill and I'd like to clarification on
why he withdrew it if anyone
knows uh the spor the issue would
somehow was resolved itself and and what
little I know um I I know the
um that Uber all those car they all have
insurance
requirements so this bill is no longer
necessary Neary correct okay thank
you okay so the motion is inexpedient to
legislate question
role representative Ammon yes a two usk
yes poost yes Cole yes MC yes belli yes
baxton Walsh yes Barrow yes
Herbert
clerk yes M
yes Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan yes
yes I yeah okay votes vote carries it oh
18 Z 18 to zip all those in favor of
placing on the consent Calendar please
say I I those was opposed so moved
unanimously uh we're now on to Senate
Bill
325 uh representative of hunt second by
representative buroughs moves
inexpedient to
legislate um is there any discussion on
igl see none the clerk will call the
role
representative Ammon yes pusk yes post
yes Co yes MCU yes aell yes Daxton yes
Walsh yes barrows yes Herbert yes Clark
yes Mair
yes wait a second I've got all some old
sheets
here
place she was recycling old cheese well
yeah she was she's got some the names
are right here that's good okay it's
yes
spear yes Sullivan yes grassy yes and
rafter
yes all right and chairman hunt
yes 18 to zero vote is 18 to zip all
those in favor placing on the consent
Calendar please say I I those opposed so
moved
unanimously Senate Bill
423 representative spear second by
representative hunt moves inexpedient to
legislate
motion being none the clerk will call
the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
poost yes Cole yes migu yes belli yes
back
yes Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert
Gibbs
spear yes Sullivan grassy yes rafter yes
chamman hunt yes 18 to zero okay vote 18
to zip all those in favor of placing on
the consent Calendar please say I I
unanimously down to our last liquor
pusk Amendment uh ought to pass on the
amendment
is
this
okay yes yeah it just had a redundant
phrase in it yeah the 2500 made in
English again well it was
redundant could still be English Okay
motion is a to pass on the amendment any
just amendment number
8888 any discussion on the
motion seeing none the clerk will call
the
role right representative Ammon yes
pusk post yes Cole yes MCU yes jelly yes
Daxton Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
clerk yes M
yes Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan grassy
yes rafter yes and chairman hunt
yes 18 to zero okay Amendment the motion
now is ought to pass as amended on
motion
see
none you know when that used to have a
me I would just cross out whatever is at
the top of the page the number is wrong
is that what's wrong no it's just
because just the Nam just the Nam the
names yeah okay I got it so this is now
to pass as amended yeah she's just
cleaning out the drawer because this is
our last
time
okay representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes M yes belli
yes Daxton Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert
yes clerk yes maclir yes Gibbs yes spear
yes Sullivan grassy yes rafter yes and
yes 18 to zero 18 to zero uh motion now
is ought to pass as
amended just did we we just did that oh
okay all right so all those in favor of
placing on the consent Calendar please
say I hi
those opposed
mov was looking I just okay last but not
least Senate Bill
433 representative SEC
uh second by representative
buo moves uh to pass on the
amendment for Senate Bill
okay any discussion on the motion on
amendment see
none the clerk will call the role on a
to pass on the
and representative Ammon yes Tusk yes
post yes Cole yes M yes pelli yes taxton
yes Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes
clerk yes M yes Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan yes grassy yes raor yes Jam
yes 18 to zero okay representative pusk
second by representative buo moves a to
clear that clerk will call the
rooll if she has any more
more just you could just be recycle this
one just the draw line down that's what
I used to
right okay okay the clerk will call the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
poost yes Cole yes M yes belli
yes taxton yes
Walsh Burrows yes Herbert yes clerk yes
M
yes
Gibbs spear
Sullivan grassy
yes rter
yes and chairman hunt yes 18 to zero
okay motion carries 18 zip all those in
favor placing on the consent Calendar
please say I I who's opposed so moved
unanimously okay uh I have two Committee
of conferences here so for your new new
members uh I'm not I'm sure we must I
don't remember what happened last year
but so um when a bill that we have sent
over to the Senate gets amended by the
Senate it then comes back
uh for us to for
concurrence and uh on my sheet now
because the the chair actually makes the
motion few things that the chair has has
some control over and um in which that
it's uh either concur non-c concur or
non-c Concur and request a committee of
conference and at that point if if
that's the motion you uh the we have the
house has four
appointees and the first requirement of
the appointees is that theoretically
they had voted for the house bill in
session on on session day so that that
is documented that they have uh on the
floor now if you know in terms of if it
wasn't if there wasn't a voice if it was
a Voice vote or a non-vote I mean
theoretically um they could go back to
the committee as a chairman I would go
back to the committee vote and see what
was the vote and see so the reason I say
that is because you theoretically would
have three Republicans and one Democrat
um and so therefore the issue is whether
that one Democrat could you just explain
the the breakdown three Republicans why
just just want I just want to understand
why it's three and
one uh it's basic it's actually in our
rules it's written into our rules that
that's the way the breakdown is three
depending on who's in majority it
depending on the major decided it was
going to be three in one so if if you
know if if you were in the
chair it would mean
when
c three it would three Democrats and one
Republican okay just and and just I'm
sorry this and is it also true with a
committee that there doesn't have to be
a bipartisan breakdown the committee we
just did for the ecigarettes so the the
committee this has nothing to do with I
understand that that committee yeah that
that committee they you always try to
have one person on the minority party
they don't state it but that yes the
depends who's who's The Speaker okay got
it it depends on the speaker you want to
throw me under the bus again
no no I said the speaker you want to
throw him on the bus again speaker you
yeah okay so um so so they will now take
them up I have first one was um the cond
the Condominium Association and I
believe I sent everybody out you got the
side by sides and there's anybody have
any any questions or any feelings about
how they basically says the same thing
it just they rewrote it in another way
to thetically to make it easier for the
condo association to understand what
what's happening so does anybody have a
problem with that otherwise I will
concur
Concur and and I initial it
okay the other one is a liquor
one and this is uh our famous increasing
the penalties for on- premise lienes for
over serving alcohol um in this case
there is the motion would actually be
made by two chairs because after the
bill left us it then went over to
criminal justice uh so uh representative
Roy would also have the opportunity to
sign off um I I pointed out to him that
this particular Amendment
which was deleting um a penalty for the
second Offense for a minum and I said
that's really up more up your alley than
ours because that's a
criminal so I I said I was I would lean
to his opinion he was okay with it and
uh and then I know I spoke to some of
the members of this committee already
and people felt comfortable that
represent Solomon so is there anybody uh
so I am prepared to concur do there
anybody have a opinion differently
representative pusc thank you Mr
chairman uh I'd like to ask the
representatives from The Liquor
Commission uh the Senate
removed uh a minimum of 15
days uh and they they just change it to
a maximum of 30 but there is no minimum
uh I'd like to ask the commission's
good morning Chief good morning Mr
chairman for record Mark armaganian uh
Chief and director of liquor enforcement
licensing um thank you for your question
representative um again being neutral on
this uh as always uh we do see that
taking away minimums and up taking away
the hard deck um and opens an
interpretation but at the same time by
rule and through our hearings process
those minimums um can still be uh in
place uh just by virtue of a caseby
casee basis not just broad brushing
everything so um we don't look at it as
a total
negative um but at the same time uh that
that's our stance on taking away
minimums it leaves a broader
interpretation okay thank you more
discretion
yeah okay any other questions for gief
from beginning seeing none thank you
very much thank you okay anybody have a
problem with this otherwise I will
concur all right so what will happen on
the floor is that um the motion will be
made to my concurrence and you will see
me down there and briefly describe what
the bill the amendment did and and urge
the house to
concur chairman before we
break what before we break yes
I when because we need to get a floor
Amendment out when can you myself and
Anita get together we're we're now out
of exact session oh okay okay so um uh
terms of uh what I would like to do if
you if it's okay with you is that I will
make a stab at it myself and I will draw
something up and and get it to you when
and you'll but I you'll do it fairly
soon yes and I said I would absolutely
get it to you okay I just because I'm
looking at her for you doesn't mean I
don't mean you you
all okay I like it Mr chairman when when
can I when should I be looking out for
it
um I I I would say uh if I get it to you
by Friday it would be a miracle so M Mr
chairman but I don't need to have it
ready until you know I know but we got
to get through OS and we all have to
agree I yeah and we have to agree on it
and word smmi or whatever we do I don't
know what we're going to do yeah I I
will I'm fully confident that what I
give you you're going to think is
wonderful I hope so because I've spent
too many too many sleepless nights over
this already well should not do that
don't let this job get to you they don't
pay you enough for
that yes represent I was just going to
say since it won't be coming out until
Friday anyways and it'll be on the
weekend it'll be working this will be an
amendment that'll be in CAC it's not in
the calendar it'll be actually in the C
correct that's correct okay all right so
uh don't forget June 15th uh so I'm not
buying you lunch today um I'm buying you
dinner when You' come to the castle uh
we will it uh if the hopefully the
weather is good so bring your bathing
suit and uh otherwise um bring lior you
do not need to bring liquor unless you
unless you have you drink something that
I would never have
Andy
Moxy
uh right if if you have a refreshment
that you want to make sure I have be
sure to let me know head a time but
otherwise otherwise so yes so this the
the purpose of this is so everybody gets
a chance to see the castle and get a
tour the day we want to see okay so yeah
it's you know starts in the afternoon
like you say if you come early and go
for a swim whatever June 15 Jun June
15th what time say come you know come
whenever I mean I mean with dinner will
probably be around five and there would
have is for the renters not for
me and this is it's going to be a dam
fundraiser right well that's true I
should are we going to have to pay $100
per car shake down Lobby well your
website said anything more than 10 cars
we have to pay $100 I I would urge you
to disregard any Co policy requirements
we have on our I read car manuals you
of
e